The lion queen of the animal kingdom is trying to improve her democracy.
She recently allowed citizens to elect representatives to join the jungle council to rule the kingdom.
However, she found that her citizens were very unhappy with the voting system.
Let us look at the elections on a small island in her kingdom to understand the reasons:
On this island, there are three political parties, two of which are big parties: the parrot party and the lizard party.
There is also a small party: the parrot parrot party
On election day, citizens voted for each vote.
They want to represent their own candidates in their constituency. The election results are as follows:
The entire island averaged, the lizard got 49% of the votes, the parrot got 48%, and the parrot got 3%.
The rules of the election are simple majority, which means that the candidate with the most votes wins.
Because lizards have the most votes in the constituency, they control 100% of the seats in the parliament.
This is why many citizens are unhappy, most of them.
That is, 51% of the voters voted for other parties, but none of them even
The Lion Queen thinks this is unfair, but she is not sure how to solve this problem.
After all, citizens want to have local representatives, but they don’t want to change the constituency.
Fortunately, the kiwi, a citizen of the island, gave a suggestion to the lion queen.
This advice can make her system more perfect while retaining local representatives.
And don't have to change the selection
This idea is called "mixed proportional representation", or MMP, and it has two changes.
The seats in the parliament are doubled; and each citizen casts two votes instead of one
The system works like this:
First of all, on the election day, the Kiwi bird is still the same as before.
He got a list of candidates who were running for his local constituency.
The kiwi bird has one, and the winner will be the one with the most votes.
So far, the status of the election is still the same.
The lizards still won all local elections, and more than half of the citizens were not represented.
However, the second ticket of the kiwi, and the newly added half of the seats, will change all this.
Kiwi took his second vote and chose his favorite party.
These second votes, after counting the votes, showed
Proportion of every party supporter among all citizens
And reveals how many imbalances in the seats in the parliament
In order to correct this imbalance, the party members of the party were added one by one.
Until the proportion of the parliament is consistent with the voters
Lizards are the most proportionate, while parrots are the most
So the parrots got the first vacant seat.
Continue this process and increase the seats of the parrot party until the lizards and parrots are out of proportion
And the parrots are still below proportion, so they got the last seat.
Now, the representatives of the jungle council are close to the actual will of the citizens.
This is a huge improvement over the old simple majority system.
But this brings up a very interesting question:
Who decides, which member of the party can get these extra seats?
The practical approach is that each party publishes a list before the election.
In order, they list candidates who wish to enter the parliament’s preferences
In this way, if only one extra seat is obtained, the first place on the list will be selected.
If you get two seats, the first two will be selected, and so on.
This makes the MMP very different from other voting systems.
It makes the party a formal part of the election
This also gives party leaders more control over party members because they can
Reward or punish them by changing the ranking on the list
Although MMP has such a defect
The Lion Queen likes its other advantages very much.
Because only a small amount of votes was wasted, it almost completely eliminated the "Jerry" (constituency division manipulation)
And avoiding a few dominant majority
By encouraging political pluralism, it also gives citizens more choices.
This is worth talking about.
Note that after using MMP, the proportion of voters voted for local representatives and
The proportion of the party is different. This is because when choosing a representative
Citizens must use strategies to vote
For example, the voters of the cockatoo don’t like lizards at all, but they can tolerate parrots.
Because the parrots have too few voters, they know that their candidates have no chance to choose.
So the real game is between two big parties.
Therefore, many cockroaches will vote for the parrot in the hope that he will win and become his representative.
However, when they vote for their favorite party, this strategy is useless.
The more votes a party receives, the more seats it gets in the parliament.
So citizens can freely vote for small parties because they know that each vote is effective.
The Lion Queen checked these backup options and decided to convert her kingdom election system to MMP
Finally, the jungle council now truly reflects the actual needs of her citizens.
Thank you for watching!